je sais pas si vous avez vu mais la
mairie de Paris vient de mettre en place
un groupe de travail pour que les
Parisiens apprennent à cohabiter avec
les rats c'est un truc de fou ça y est
ça y est maintenant ouais tu vas inviter
des Raches chez toi tu vas tranquille
quoi les chasse plume on a plus le
principe c'est d'abandonner les préjugés
envers les rats ça veut dire que
maintenant comme ils peuvent plus rien
faire ils vont essayer de nous persuader
que Laura c'est un truc de ouf tu vois
que maintenant tu peux manger avec un
rats aussi
on est mort on peut
plus rien ils ont pas ils sont reliés
mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour les
embrouiller et si on disait que les
rails étaient super euh mais par contre
parce que je te le dis ouais on peut
dire que l'irage genre c'est un truc de
fou que les gens qui feraient des rats
mais après tu vas avoir des mariages
humains rares hein
mais je te le dis ça va arriver tu vois
avec ma van Hidalgo elle va arriver
est-ce que tu veux bien prendre pour
époux madame Daniel Moreau
oui merci bon moi je considère ça comme
un oui voilà merci et de aimer la chérie
jusqu'à ce que la mort vous sépare quand
même pas euh je viens de me dire qu'il
avait déjà épousé un rat
les deux vous êtes
avec vous
non c'est quoi l'histoire tu dis que
j'avais une blague
faites-vous des blagues
pour l'instant on est on fait une
émission quand même euh regardez
évidemment ça ne passe pas pour tout le
monde en particulier pour le maire du
17e Geoffroy Boulard il s'appelle
Geoffroy Boulard Geoffroy a raison il
est vénère je crois voilà et pourtant il
y a pas du tout le melon regarde
la mesure du problème ne souhaite pas le
faire par idéologie puisqu'ils
expliquent que voilà les Parisiens
peuvent s'accommoder d'une cohabitation
avec avec les rats il y a des maladies
qui se développent c'est porteur de
pathogènes et moi je je suis sidéré
devant tant d'incompétence c'est tout à
fait inacceptable inacceptable de
laisser Paris comme ça c'est l'image
qu'on renvoie à 44 millions de visiteurs
étrangers chaque année
certainement des surmulos c'est très
sympa vous avez vu là en plein Paris
au début on nous disait vous inquiétez
pas vous débarrasser des rails faut
accepter c'est comme ça limite c'est
nous qui habitons chez eux c'est
n'importe quoi non mais c'est quoi
ensuite on va devoir les accueillir dans
notre chambre d'amis et leur servir à
bouffer c'est c'est il y a plus de
limite en fait on habite chez l'air je
te le dis il n'y a plus de limite sur
les reins il n'y a plus de limites je le
dis je le répète il n'est plus limite
sur le rat oui 5 à 6 millions d'Arabes à
Paris donc 4e ville au monde
rappelons-le quand même et aujourd'hui
pour la mairie de Paris et c'est triste
à dire la guerre du rat c'est perdu
c'est à dire qu'ils ont renoncé à ça et
maintenant ils disent bah alors voilà on
va verbaliser peut-être les gens qui
mettent leurs déchets on va faire de la
prévention donc ça ne sert à rien il
renonce à combattre il renonce à
utiliser aussi les qui sont utilisés
dans d'autres villes quand vous vous
promenez dans des villes en ce moment en
région parisienne vous voyez plein de
pancartes attention aura faites
attention à Paris il y a rien on voit
rien on a renoncé à ce bac contre
maintenant ils se disent ouais on va
essayer de les persuader que le rat
c'est pas mauvais en fait voilà de de
nous expliquer que il n'y aurait pas de
problème sanitaire
l'adjointe la santé du maire de Paris
qui s'appelle madame sourire en plus à
dire
elle a dit elle a dit qu'en fait ça
n'était dangereux qu'évançait les
éboueurs et alors que l'Académie de
médecine dit que c'est porteurs de
fièvre hémorragiques l'hépatite E et la
leptocirose 5% il va y avoir une
catastrophe
dans les bac à sable
des bienfaits pour la peau
d'échec
c'est très grave dans une école un jour
vous allez voir parce qu'il commence à y
avoir dans les écoles
il va avoir un vrai problème mais ils
vont dire ouais mes comme d'habitude ça
va on va pas entendre parler c'est que
personne n'est content de comment y
gérer Paris aussi bien au niveau des
travaux de la circulation des rats donc
des surmulos et pour autant elle est
enfin la mère a été réunie en fait donc
il y a un moment donné aussi il faut
qu'il y a un réveil des malgré tout
les élections
mais toujours par très peu de gens mais
toujours est-il que elle est réélu donc
un peu bizarre oui pour expliquer
comment ça se passe en fait c'est par on
va dire c'est pas arrondissement donc il
suffit d'avoir un bon découpage
électoral et puis la ville elle est je
dirais pas noyau et à gauche mais elle
est faite maintenant pour que la gauche
repasse tout le temps mais ceci dit
faute de rival sérieuse ou de Rives au
sérieux elle a fait la différence c'est
vrai il y a pas quelqu'un qui s'impose à
droite pour le moment qui ne sait pas
imposer
dans Paris
[Musique]
avec mon boulanger je connais bien à
côté de chez moi mais il a les souris
comme tout le monde il a Dora dans sa
boulangerie
il y a toujours un moment parce que ça
merde de chat demeure qui sont là pour
chasser les chaussettes mais moi chez
moi moi chez moi je l'ai déjà dit je
voulais mettre un vraiment genre comme
un achat de combat
comme un centre vraiment de préparation
de charge
mais déjà comment ça avec des boules
et genre avec des passards sécurité ils
tournent comme as dans la zone il y a un
rat il doit pratiquer le défonce mon
frère je veux des chats tu vois des
chats ils arrivent frère ouais qu'est-ce
qui t'arrive tu vois ils sont devant la
maison ouais j'ai vu un rat moi je veux
un rare vraiment je veux un instructeur
de rat Bruno pommade voilà
[Rires]
maintenant on va aller voir les les
copains du splip donc pour voir comment
appréhender donc cette partie de rap non
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai mais
moi je suis complètement d'accord avec
toi je veux dire et je j'en ai parlé
avec plein de monde
le mieux mais alors attention c'est pas
des chats c'est des chats
j'arrive le chat
je fais c'est bon tu es pris si je suis
griffé à sang je glisse c'est bon tu vas
dans le jardin tu vas défoncer ton
sourire exactement
[Rires]
chez vous jamais moi je fais contrôler
pratiquement toutes les semaines ah oui
sérieux toutes les semaines pratiquement
ici
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
écoute-moi bien je le dis s'il y a des
rats qui m'écoutent dans votre piscine
qui vient je le dis ils peuvent aller
partout chez nous on est à l'affût il y
a un rat on va l'attraper je te dis ça
va très mal passé
[Rires]
je fais le nécessaire ah d'accord c'est
quoi le nécessaire
c'est pas la bonne idée voilà ils
arrivent comme ça chez toi
on rigole les chéris mais attention
je peux vous dire que c'est porteur de
maladie et moi je suis d'accord avec toi
il faut des chats il faut des chats mais
il faut des commander la ville de chats
[Rires]
sur le coin de la bouche ça vient de
l'été les spectateurs pique-nique
voilà donc on va voir mais c'est vrai
que on en rigole mais c'est c'est
extrêmement grave il y a pas de solution
il y a pas de solution il y a des
solutions normalement il faut juste
mettre des budget c'est tout mais quand
le problème ils veulent pas mettre le
budget bah forcément tu te retrouves
comme des boutiques
un maire et qui arrive et qui disait mec
moi je vais allouer tant pour les rats
parce que c'est il va y avoir un drame
dans un parc un truc comme ça avec un
enfant et ça va partir en cacahuète une
priorité municipale exactement
Paris ça aide bien les jeux pour les
Jeux Olympiques avec tous les rats tu
vas voir que tu vas avoir des rats qui
vont lancer des javelot
avec tous les touristes qui vont filmer
les rats dans les rues
plus faire il m'a dit
ça
c'est très intelligent il mettait des
pastilles des trucs le premier rigoler
si tu mets des pastilles
dans quoi à quoi il a réussi il a jamais
réussi à les enlever un petit jardin oui
bien sûr il est pas très bon le gars
toute la journée il fait que ça le mec
donc on va faire quoi bah non il m'a dit
apprenez alors je vais dire le seul
moyen qu'à faire c'est il faut faire
péter le jardin faut mettre des
explosifs
je te le fais si tu veux non non mais
sérieux
chez toi par exemple il y avait des
miettes par terre
[Applaudissements]
tu dormais tranquille j'ai pas tellement
peur surtout que c'était pas c'était
plus des gros bulots
avec des longues
moi j'avais eu un rat dans le temps donc
j'habitais mais ils aillent plus
comme ça en procession
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je t'explique un rat ça peut grimper euh
si tu l'attaques pas il va pas tarder
il cherche la bouffe il va pas te dés il
va pas il monte dans ton lit
[Rires]
dans une testicule un testicule ça te
fait tout le monde est tombé sur ma tête
une nuit comme ça
j'avais une étagère où tout le monde
j'avais une étagère
évidemment il montait et puis il a dû
glisser c'est un truc en aluminium il a
glissé
comme ça arrête j'ai eu peur évidemment
lui a dû avoir aussi hein mais c'est
quand même c'est pas venu devant toi
direction
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
un fascicule de tes histoires